and um you know there's sometimes that  you you know have a black have a three  whatever you just run down the other  but like for me the way i play the way i  want to play moving forward i want to  like enjoy  every single moment and that was the  moment that i felt like our team was  turning around and we were you know  getting the momentum and uh  chris was hitting big shots and uh you  know it felt good  um so so yeah to answer your question he  felt good and uh  the way we were playing felt good at the  time  right here in the center be honest this  was the second game in a row you went  out early in the first quarter i'm just  curious what was going on there  i wanted uh what the hell you guys say  politely i want to take a tinkle  a tinkle yeah yeah  i went to take a tinkle it came back  that's it that's that's polite right  tinkle is for the yeah  both games i want to take a tinkle back  last question jeff